foreign
[Music]
I'm a senior director in the AMD Cloud
business unit
mainly responsible for driving go to
market strategy and execution for our
Cloud business
today marks exactly my third anniversary
at AMD and every single moment of those
three years
I've been really excited in bringing
compute Solutions in partnership with
Google Cloud to our customer base all of
you guys
I'll spend the next 30 to 35 minutes to
walk you through all the GCE and gke
solutions powered by AMD epic CPUs in
Google Cloud
that would leave us roughly about five
to ten minutes in the end
for Q a
and I recommend if I suggest if you can
hold on to your questions till the end
come to the mic and ask your questions
that way the broader audience will be
able to listen to your question and
we'll have a more meaningful discussion
with that what are we waiting for let's
get started
before I actually dive into the AMD epic
driven GCE and gke Solutions in Google
Cloud let me give you a little bit of
overview of AMD as a company
AMD is not only just a server CPU
provider anymore
we have established ourselves in the
last couple of years as true holistic
data center Solutions company
starting to the left if you see far left
it's the AMD epic line of server CPUs
targeted towards Enterprise and
Commercial HPC workloads both on-prem
and in the cloud
with generative AI large language models
inference and training being the most
talked about the most sought after
workloads
we're very excited with the AMD Instinct
line of gpus
they are really the Mi 250 in production
right now and Mi 300X coming out in Q4
we are again very excited to really put
the solution in front of our end
customers which is again targeting AIML
large language models
last year we acquired two companies
xilinx which is the leading provider of
programmable fpga Solutions and adaptive
socs we acquired xilinx
around the first quarter of last year
and what that did for us is it increa it
increased or expanded our Damned from
just server data center to like markets
such as Telco
markets such as embedded fintech so on
and so forth
we also added pin Sandos which is a
programmable P4 based smartnic dpu
company and what that did for us is it
provided us with a companion smart neck
as companion chip which actually
offloads some of the infrastructure
workloads such as crypto
storage compression decompression
networking encryption decryption it
uploaded the CPU and brought it into the
smartnet dpu which is P4 programmable
again and that leaves more cores for end
user application
so this basically completed our holistic
data center solution kind of strategy
and now we are in execution mode
all right so in this session we're going
to mainly Focus out of the four uh
Solutions I showed in the previous slide
we're going to mainly focus on the AMD
epic line of server CPUs
there are lots of benefits multiple
benefits from the AMD epic architecture
starting with uh TCO if you look at AMD
epic all the way from Naples to Rome to
Milan and now to Genoa it provides the
highest x86 core density with the
industry leading performance per core if
you multiply the core density per socket
with performance per core what that
gives you is an extremely compelling PCO
which is not only beneficial to a
hyperscaler Partners like Google Cloud
but a lot of that is passed on to the
end customers in terms of either
performance per core or in terms of
dollar per VM and that if if you are
optimizing for cost that gives you an
excellent uh cost efficient
infrastructure if you're optimizing for
performance same thing
a lot of Enterprises now are also
optimizing I I the sustainability aspect
of it their social responsibility aspect
of it the Enterprises are not only
optimizing or reducing their scope 1 and
scope 2 emissions they want to really
optimize their scope three emissions for
workloads they are migrated to Cloud
AMD epic CPUs with the latest tsmc 5
nanometer technology and the chiplet
architecture is the most energy
efficient x86 CPU that you'll find out
there
so that's again a big Advantage from the
AMD epic architecture
next is the ecosystem
lots of Enterprises have been running
their x86 applications for 10 years 20
years 30 years
you really did not want to go touch
those applications that have been
bringing business to you that have been
interfacing to your customer base and
add risk and effort by putting that to a
different architecture
so AMD epic again based on the x86
architecture and available in all GEOS
within Google Cloud gives you that ease
of migration for your workloads that you
were hosting on-prem but now you can
easily do that in the cloud
last but not the least confidential
compute
verticals and markets such as Healthcare
FSI public sector one of the key
hesitant hesitation in moving the
workloads to cloud is will my workload
be secure will my application be secure
will my application my data in the cloud
be secure so confidential compute in
Google cloud is exclusively powered by
AMD epic VMS both confidential VMS and
confidential containers Within gke
all right so now let's really go dive
into I'm going to skip this one really
dive into the different families uh
compute families we have powered by AMD
epic in Google Cloud one size does not
fit all anymore when we started our
journey and our partnership with Google
Cloud we only had the general purpose
VMS powered by second gen AMD epic code
named Rome
and since then we have gone from general
purpose we have added to the portfolio
of general purpose n2d VMS computer
optimize c2d VMS
Cloud native optimized Tau vmc 2D VMS
and confidential VMS so starting with
n2d VMS to your left these are really
targeted towards your Enterprise lift
and shift workloads such as web and app
servers
small to medium sized databases line of
business applications like media
encoding transcoding it really provides
you a very easy button lift and shift
from on-prem to Cloud for mainstream
Enterprise workloads
but as I said
one size does not fit all when you look
at the cloud HPC Market which basically
right now uh according to Hyperion
research is about six to seven billion
dollars and it is gonna go at a cargo of
about 17 percent between now and 2026 to
about 11 to 12 billion dollars
your commercial HPC applications
Automotive Aerospace r d designs
computational fluid dynamics drug
Discovery Oil and Gas and energy
exploration these kind of workloads
really require compute intensive
infrastructure with very Ultra fast High
performing cores the highest memory
bandwidth per core
highest memory capacity per core and
also very tight very fast networking low
latency networking for your tightly
coupled workloads that's where we kind
of launched c2d VMS uh in 2021 in
partnership with Google Cloud
now right at that time we also realized
that there is a need to really provide a
highest price performance Cloud native
uh
architecture or VMS which are targeted
towards scale out workloads and AMD and
Google Cloud combined and co-engineered
this new family of VMS called Tau VMS
t2d which was based on third generation
AMD epic Milan and these provide up to
42 percent better
price performance and 56 percent better
performance compared to any other VMS
available on Google cloud or elsewhere
and I kind of touched a little bit about
confidential compute both entity and c2d
families have confidential VM capability
and feature support and also
confidential gkes supported on these two
VMS
okay
let's kind of double click into each of
these VM families starting with n2d I
just mentioned that n2d is really
targeted towards your mainstream
Enterprise workloads
uh web serving think about app serving
Java applications think about databases
both SQL and nosql think about uh just
line of business applications like media
encoding transcoding uh gaming and so on
and so forth
so these general purpose VMS entity we
started off with second gen epic with
Rome in 2020 and they were refreshed
with 3rd gen epic Milan in 2021 these
provide these entity VMS general purpose
VMS or the highest VM density or highest
VM size you will find in Google cloud
with 224 vcpus as the highest VM size
there are also 13 percent lower cost
compared to comparable n-series
instances available on Google Cloud
so again think about highest performing
VM
per core multiplied by lower 13 percent
lower cost per VM really gives you that
TCO advantage that I was talking about
earlier
and if you see the charts to the right
what we did is we benchmarked entity
Milan which is the third generation epic
with n2d ROM and it provides about 30
percent Better Price performance for
workloads such as nginx databases MySQL
so on and so forth
so now let's talk about couple of
partners and customers who have really
leveraged and benefited from migrating
to entity VMS sap which is the leading
Enterprise business software provider
think Erp CRM so on and so forth they
chose entity VMS for their as a default
for their rise with sap program
the main reason why they chosen to do
VMS was the price performance benefit
and the global availability of these VMS
the other two customers I want to
highlight that really benefited and
adapted the entity VMS is Salesforce we
all know about Salesforce here
Salesforce for similar reasons to sap
adapted entity VMS to host its industry
leading Enterprise CRM SAS solution in
Google Cloud
Vimeo is a leading content and uh video
provider
it's also a SAS provider hosting on
Google Cloud they saw 20 lower
transcoding time or faster transcoding
video transcoding using n2d VMS compared
to the previous infrastructure they were
using they also at the same time save 20
cost while hosting on entity VMS on
Google Cloud
all right
so we talked a little bit about general
purpose entity VMS
let's switch over to compute optimized
HPC focused c2d VMS these VMS again are
targeted towards more technical
workloads which are very compute
intensive computational fluid dynamics
for automotive and Aerospace energy
exploration for oil and gas weather
forecasting by by national agencies
those are the workloads that are very
compute intensive Network intensive
because they are tightly coupled and
also memory bandwidth intensive
so with c2dv amps
it's available it's also the highest VM
size as far as compute intensive
workloads or VMS are concerned in Google
Cloud it provides up to 112 vcpus at the
largest size and you can rent out the
entire node to really host in a sole
tenancy mode
just like entity VMS compared to other
n-series V and c2d VMS are also offered
by Google Cloud at 13 lower cost
compared to comparable C Series VMS
it also provides 30 Better Price
performance compared to general purpose
entity VMS as you could see from the
chart to the right
but more interestingly I want to kind of
quote two customers who benefited from
migrating to c2d VMS air shaper is an
online aerodynamic simulation platform
company
and they saw 50 reduction in their
overall simulation costs and 30 percent
faster simulation times when they
migrated to c2d VMS and clutch which is
a marketing and data analytics company
providing the features and data
analytics features at real-time
analytics to end Enterprises saw similar
benefits of adopting C to D
on this slide let me sum up all the
features that are available on n2d and
c2d starting with the top left
I mentioned earlier and we're going to
talk a little bit about confidential VMS
both entity and c2d offer
confidential compute capability and comp
confidential VMS and confidential
container capability powered by AMD
secure encrypted virtualization sap
technology we're going to talk about it
in just a little bit
they both also support
um 100 up to 100 gigabit per second
networking very fast networking which
provides enough networking bandwidth per
core
really required for HPC workloads in c2d
and large size Enterprise workloads VM
size and n2d
both also offer local ssds
n2d offers up to nine terabytes of local
ssds and c2d offers up to three
terabytes of local ssds for our for your
really IO iops intensive workloads
and finally both these are available in
sole tenancy configuration so if you
belong to an Enterprise which is
concerned about security from
neighboring VMS or multi in a
multi-tenancy mode or let's say if your
Enterprise which you're mainly running
on-prem and you're doing lift and shift
to the cloud and bringing your own
license these VMS in a soul tenancy mode
allows you more flexibility it allows
you more direct lift and shift to Google
Cloud
um compared to multi-tenancy options
all right
so so far we talked about
general purpose and to dvms
and compute optimized c2d VMS
let's kind of double click a little bit
about these completely new family that
Google and AMD co-engineered which is
the Tau VMS t2dvms
these are available from vcpu sizes from
2 all the way to 60 vcpus
and and again as I mentioned they were
co-engineered really to serve one
purpose
a lot of cloud native scale out
workloads
needed a reason to really go migrate to
the cloud because obviously the cloud
architecture provides that scale out
capability one of the key um blockers if
you if I if you will were like does it
provide me the right price performance
so AMD and Google co-engineered this
from a performance site to provide the
industry best performance so it provides
up to 42 sorry 56 up to 56 percent
better performance compared to any other
VMS in gcp or elsewhere
but to top it off and another icing on
the cake Google Cloud
really priced this very aggressively to
give you up to 42 percent Better Price
performance uh compared to any other VMS
available elsewhere and you can see some
of the charts to the right which shows
the price performance comparisons
two of the leading social media and
collaboration companies Twitter now X is
hosting on t2d VMS because of the price
performance value prop we provide in the
cloud native scale out capability
because these these workloads these
applications are very elastic in nature
depending on how much news how much uh
users are using it so they needed that
kind of flexibility at a good price
Performance Point which was the main
reason that brought Twitter onto t2d
same with Snapchat snap really adapted
t2d technology or t2dvns exactly for the
same reasons
all right so
let's recap we talked about general
purpose and 2D VMS we talked about
compute optimized HPC c2d VMS we talked
about Cloud native scale out Tau VMS
one of the features that is exclusively
available only on AMD VMS in Google
cloud is confidential compute what is
confidential compute
historically if you look at data and the
journey of data from on-prem to Edge to
Cloud
data is moving it's in transit data is
in rest at rest within the disks and
nvmes but there's also data in use being
processed in the CPUs
for decades there have been Technologies
to really encrypt and secure both data
at rest and data in motion data in
motion is secured by ipsack kind of at
the network data at rest in the distance
secured by all the AES encryption
Technologies
the hole we had over here was how do you
secure the data
in use or being processed the data and
use are being processed if you think
about multiple multi-tenancy VMS running
on the same host
you need to make sure that your data in
your VM is protected and secured from
Rogue in malicious VMS neighboring VMS
and it's also protected from the Rogue
and malicious hypervisor and also the
zero trust model says that it needs to
be protected by your cloud service
provider and the Silicon provider like
Google cloud and AMD itself it's a
completely zero trust model that's where
amd's secure encrypted virtualization
SUV technology
comes to play and Google was the first
hyperscaler to adopt this SUV technology
and launch confidential VMS and
confidential compute containers based on
this technology
we can literally spend one hour going
deep in depth but don't worry I'm not
going to do that
let me narrowed out of what SUV is what
SUV is is it provides within every AMD
epic chip there is a hardware there's a
secure processor which provides a
hardware route of trust that encrypts
the data not only in the main memory but
also the data in the CPU registers that
is being processed
it manages the hardware encryption Keys
such that only the hardware knows what
those keys are and your data center
operator does not have access to those
keys what that does is provides a zero
trust model uh to secure your Federated
data or your regulated data
I think the key points over here without
going into the details is you guys
probably are not interested in the
sausage making behind this but the key
takeaways from this is two things one
you can enable Sev and confidential VMS
and containers by a push button within
the Google Cloud UI
there is no need to touch your
application code that you have been
running stably for 10 years 20 years 30
years uh to make it secure just click a
button in your workload all the hardware
encryption root of Russia is enabled and
all taken care of by Hardware
it provides confidentiality which means
nobody can go and steal your data it
provides and it provides secure
Integrity which means nobody can go and
corrupt your data
and it also provides attestation at a
hardware route of trust level
the last and final thing that you should
remember is
we spend a lot of time benchmarking what
is the performance impact if you turn on
This SUV confidential compute feature
and it is almost minimal to zero impact
on your workload performance so you are
getting a lot of automated security
without having to give up too much on
your performance or at all
so
there are a couple of things I want to
mention here uh just what's available
available today
with AMD SUV technology that provides
your confidentiality
um confidentiality not Integrity yet is
in general availability on entity and
c2d VMS both confidential VMS and
containers and what is in preview which
was announced is SCV SNP which actually
provides the memory Integrity protection
what that means is
nobody else a malicious hypervisor or
malicious VM or a data center operator
not only can they not steal your data
they can also not corrupt your data so
that was just announced it is in public
preview and will go in GA very soon and
uh SUV feature is available on n2d and
c2d whereas the Sev SNP feature in
public preview is enabled on n2d right
now
all right more importantly
I want to talk about couple of customers
who belong to a very regulated Federated
industry AstraZeneca that we all know
about is a
Healthcare biosciences Company who
really develops uh vaccines for many
different types of diseases they store a
lot of confidential client data
and it is of utmost importance for them
that that information is not leaked out
that information is not corrupted that
information is not stolen
they really Leverage The confidential
VMS for n2d and c2d to do that and icon
is another blockchain FSI fintech
company which really leveraged the
confidential VMS powered by AMD CV
technology on Google Cloud as well
all right so so far just a quick recap
talked about history talked about
AMD as a company as a solution provider
talked about General per person to dvms
talked about compute optimize c2dvms
talked about Cloud native T to dvms
typed a little bit about confidential
VMS this brings us to the exciting news
for this week
Google Cloud just announced yesterday
that next gen general purpose VMS c3d
VMS powered by amd's latest 4th gen epic
CPUs code name Genoa so this was
announced yesterday we are very excited
about it before I get into c3d VMS and
what it provides uh to you as a customer
base let me talk a little bit about uh
Genoa first
Genoa is Industries highest core density
highest performance per core x86 CPU
it packs 96 up to 96 cores of highest
performing x86 course within a single
socket and that's the part that has also
gone into the c3d VMS
it also provides up to 9 2.9 terabytes
of memory per node
on top of it it provides 12 ddr5 memory
channels attached to the CPU provides
the highest memory bandwidth per socket
and highest memory bandwidth per core
this is very critical for HPC workloads
and even some in-memory databases
and then there are 160 PCI 5 Lanes which
really drives the highest iops available
on this platform for your i o intensive
workloads
so I talked about c3d a little bit uh
this is in preview this will go into
preview very soon but uh it's available
uh in various shapes uh all the way up
to 360 vcpus with 2.9 terabytes of
um of ram as I mentioned of ddr5 and
it's 4800 Mega transfers per second is
the bandwidth or the speed uh and again
targeted towards your mainstream general
purpose workloads so the first thing we
do when we get this is uh and sorry
before I get there we also upped the
total networking bandwidth on this
compared to n2d it now offers 200
gigabit per second networking bandwidth
per node compared to 100 gigabit per
second that was there in n2d so if you
add up
highest number of course highest
performance per core 200 gigabit per
second networking fastest i o available
iops available that translates into real
world performance uplifts and we
benchmarked this with the Google Cloud
engineering team and we are seeing 45
better performance on c3d VMS on an
average across all the critical
workloads like web serving engine X
in-memory caching databases like readers
relational databases like MySQL and Java
workloads as benchmarked by spec jbb so
45 average higher performance which is a
huge step function jump generationally
compared to the Milan based into dvms
all right so this is my last slide
it's no good if we have great technology
but not available in your GEOS and
regions so we work constantly and
continuously with Google Cloud to really
grow the footprint quarter of over
quarter so with the exception of c3d
which is just in preview right now all
of our other VMS are available in
multiple GEOS across the world wherever
your Enterprises or your data center
operations are and with c3d now
announced in preview and going in GA
soon you will see a lot more
availability for c3d to a data center
near you
thank you